so it's no secret we have a bunch of
wonderful writers here at the show who
always write great stuff for me but I
always have to kind of reach week and
make sure things are in my voice but not
tonight tonight I thought I'd give them
an opportunity to write stuff for me
that I would have to say word-for-word
without any changes this was their idea
so keep in mind I have no idea what they
wrote I've never seen these cards before
so Teddy the envelope please okay here
we go
the writers are the most important part
of this show they're the real brains
behind this operation I'm just a puppet
minimum um uh me so horny sorry it says
put hands on hips
I'm the cupcake queen and I get real
mean and my name is diarrhea Joe just
barked like piss yourself
I can't go with people watching here's
the next one
hey everyone this is the part of the
show where I say goodnight but I can't
do it yet because I'm required to say
everything written on this card like
this sentence and this sentence and this
one here that I'm saying right now and
that last one and this one and this
pause 1 2 3 6 9 I'm not counting
correctly because I have to read what's
written
and because I have duty in my booty that
wasn't on the card